[Music]
Happy Friday greets Mejía with
headlines for October 30 Today is
the last day of
early voting and to date nearly 342,000
people have cast their ballots in person
in Clark County while more than
316,000 ballots  have been received in the
mail if you have not yet registered you have
two days to do so in person and until
the day of the presidential election
and due to the pandemic
the new year's show on the
las vegas strip the traditional
fireworks celebration has been canceled  Aircraft attracted more than
300,000 visitors last year according to
the convention authority and
visitors say they have other
special plans to
welcome the new year 2021 and that they
will reveal those plans soon
and the federal aviation agency is still
investigating the plane crash that killed
two people south of the valley yesterday a
small plane collided with the area near the
relief streets and evolved after
the pilot had  It was communication with the
control tower telling them that it had
problems the two people on board
died the federal aviation agency
says that the plane had left
north of las vegas and was heading towards
san diego the pilot was identified
as paper and it is still unknown what
caused the accident
and for the first time the American
will receive his first fans
to see the university game and an
Audi against his rival winner
tomorrow Saturday night, for his part,
officials from the health sector approved
the plan that consists of allowing only
three  percent of the capacity of
people in the stadium that is equivalent to
two thousand tickets which sold out
quickly it is known that the stadium will
also apply distancing measures
now we must talk about the
sunny and hot weather forecast for today
Friday with maximums reaching the  80
degrees this afternoon a nice day
for saturday halloween day and clouds
for sunday had u  n excellent day and it
may be I am Héctor Mejía and this was
his informative creed this year in
Spanish
[Music]